going to go now to South Carolina and
you know what is going on there the
double murder trial of disgraced
attorney Alec murdaugh it is almost over
prosecutors made their closing arguments
yesterday and the defense plans to do
the same this morning the jury will then
decide if Murda is guilty of killing his
wife and son back in June of 2021. he
testified under oath that he didn't do
it Nikki Batiste was in the court to
hear the start of closing arguments and
she joins us now from outside the
courthouse where she has been for days
Nikki another morning and you were there
good morning
we are here good morning prosecutors
deliver their closing Arguments for
about four hours yesterday jurors seem
to pay close attention though two
appeared to close their eyes at least
once during the lengthy proceedings it
comes with the end of this trial on the
horizon nearly six weeks after it began
behalf of the state of South Carolina
I ask you to return a verdict of guilty
in fiery closing arguments prosecutors
painted Alec murdal as a killer who
murdered his wife and son to avoid
confronting what they called a
descending storm of past wrongs and as a
dishonest man who used his Decades of
legal expertise to cover his tracks he
lies convincingly and easily in gripping
testimony last week murdal admitted to a
pattern of lying about his addiction to
opioids years of embezzlement his
presence at the scene on the night of
the murders and a botched suicide
attempt in their wake there is only one
person
who had the motive
who had the means
who had the opportunity
to commit these crimes
in a rare move jurors visited the crime
scene on Myrtle sprawling hunting estate
before closing arguments began bullet
holes were still visible at the dog
kennels where Paul and Maggie murdal's
bodies were found it's official that
they're dead yes sir that's what it
looks like
investigators say two guns were used in
the murders the defense argues that
means there were two Shooters
prosecutors contend that's exactly what
Murdoch wanted people to think this is
him this is Alex the prosecutor of the
lawyer and he's thinking through this
he's thought through this he's going to
use two guns because it's going to
confuse people but perhaps there were
two Shooters in closing the state begged
jurors not to be fooled by murdaugh and
he fooled Maggie and Paul too
and they paid for it with their lives
after the defense delivers its closing
argument the prosecution will have one
more opportunity to respond before the
jury begins its deliberations if murdal
is not convicted of murder he could face
life in prison for the financial crimes
he admitted to during this trial Vlad
all right Nikki Batiste for us on the
ground where she has been since the
beginning thank you Nikki